ist das größte müllproblem der
menschheit gelöst plastikmüll kaum
abbaubar verseucht der unsere umwelt
tötet ihre und landet schließlich wieder
mit gefährlichen schadstoffen
angereichert beim menschen einfach nur
eine solche dieses zeug jetzt scheint
sich aber eine lösung anzubahnen mal
wieder hat kommissar zufall seine hände
im spiel und die mottenlarven galeria
melo nella was das besondere an dieser
lage ist um wie sie das plastik müll
problem lösen kann jetzt in klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
frederica bertolini ist nicht nur
biologin an der universität santander in
spanien sondern auch hobby imkerin und
das hat ihr wahrscheinlich eine
bahnbrechende entdeckung ermöglicht
polyethylen kurz ist ein sehr
widerstandsfähiger kunststoff wodurch er
zum beispiel perfekt für
getränkeflaschen ereignis ist er ist aus
unserem alltag nicht mehr wegzudenken
und macht und 40 prozent des
hergestellten kunststoff aus aber was
ihn so widerstandsfähig macht ist auch
sein größtes problem er ist nämlich sehr
schwer abbaubar und sammelt sich an
allen ecken und enden wie zb den ozean
nach jüngsten studien hat sich die
müllmenge seit 2004 zum teil
verzwanzigfacht das gilt für die arktis
dort landet der müll zum teil durch die
meeresströmungen und zum teil wird er
auch in eis eingeschlossen und so
transportiert durch die schmelze im
frühling landet der plastikmüll dann
selbst an entlegensten orten über die
jahrzehnte wird der dann zermahlen und
landet angereichert mit schadstoffen
durch den fisch stehen wir essen dann
wieder bei uns mal zeit aber das könnte
bald ein ende haben denn viele rica
bertolini hat bei der mottenlarven
galeria melo nella erstaunliches
festgestellt diese lage ist nämlich in
der lage p zu zersetzen in kürzester
zeit frisst sich durch plastiktüten und
schon der kontakt mit ihnen zersetzt sie
das bietet für das forscherteam einen
spannenden ansatz denn offensichtlich
verfügt die läufe über ein enzym das
schon von sich aus pe in seine
bestandteile zerlegt suchen die forscher
und forscherinnen nach diesem enzym
könnte ist in großem maßstab produziert
werden wäre ein weg zum abbau von pe
gefunden von ricardo genie steht
übrigens auf die besondere fähigkeit der
lafer durch einen zufall die
mottenlarven ist nämlich in
bienenstöcken also sieht ihr hobby in
chören ein parasit und frisst das max
was einen ganz ähnlichen aufbau wie
polyethylen hat die hobby imkerin hatte
einen bienenstock von den larven befreit
und hatte sie in eine plastiktüte
gesteckt diese zerfressen sie in
kürzester zeit eine entdeckung wahr
gemacht und die larven sind dabei sogar
doppelt so schnell wie die im letzten
jahr entdeckten plastik fressen
bakterien über die wir ja hier berichtet
hatten natürlich halten wir euch über
dieses thema auch auf dem laufenden mit
der nichts verpasst wird mehr hier
aber aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke wenn der krieg so ein
bisher noch nicht abonniert haben dann
habt ihr das ihr verpasst die besten
videos von pixum science fiction und
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt dran